un exemple parmi d'autres directions la
région entre falaise et saint pierre sur
dives dans le calvados à morteaux
couliboeuf très précisément exemple des
dégâts de cette tempête dans une commune
où l'école est le château ont
particulièrement souffert
voilà ce qui reste de la salle de classe
de l'école maternelle de
morteaux-couliboeuf toute l'école a été
touché le plafond s'est écroulé peu
après la tempête le 26 vers 6 heures du
matin le toit s'est envolé en l'espace
d'une demi heure toutes et à tous et
envolées c'était le coup de vent est
arrivé force inouïe disons à prévoir on
n'a jamais vu ça un peu à bout du toit a
même été retrouvé à plus d'un kilomètre
de là jeudi matin les enfants repris
l'école dans la cantine située bien plus
loin dans la commune les enfants ne
parlait que de la tempête vous de quoi y
ait cassé le toi tu sais ils ont quand
même beaucoup de choses à dire à
dessiner je crois que ça va être le
centre de nos discussions et notre
travail encore pendant pendant quelques
semaines
il faudra attendre juin pour retrouver
l'école près de la bible château de
couliboeuf et son parc ont beaucoup
souffert des arbres plusieurs fois
centenaires ont été déracinés une des
cheminées a éventré le toit détruisant
tout sur son passage
heureusement les propriétaires parisiens
n'étaient pas là images de désolation
dans le parc également mais aussi à
l'extérieur ou des arbres sont tombés
sur les lignes électriques
elles ont été réparées au plus vite une
nouvelle occasion de rappeler surtout
aux enfants de ne pas toucher les fils